Zana color is live for us now in our
charcoal a that's near Turkey's border
with Syria let's start with the latest
as this offensive rolls on rasa Lane has
fallen to the Turks how significant is
that well undoubtedly a significant
development a blow to the Kurdish led
Syrian democratic forces it wasn't an
easy fight for the past four days
Turkish air strikes artillery targeting
the defenses of the SDF and over the
past two or three days intense clashes
street-to-street fighting so the SDF did
put up resistance it is denying that the
town has fallen but pictures are
emerging from the town city center
posted on social media by turkey's
syrian allies the opposition Syrian
National Army you see their fighters in
the centre of the town pulling down and
SDF flags as well as YPG flags of course
the YPG the Syrian Kurdish armed group
is the backbone of the SDF a group
turkey considers a terrorist
organization so a significant
development there are two main border
towns in a stretch of territory 120
kilometers stretch of territory along
the border which has been really the
focus of the ongoing operations the
Turkish Foreign Minister made it clear
the initial phase of this operation will
be to control that 120 kilometer stretch
of territory 30 kilometers deep now in
some points the Turkish army and its
allies have reached the 30 kilometer
mark they've reached the M for
international highway that connects East
and West Syria the question is will they
be able to hold their ground but if they
do they will then divide the territory
the east of the Euphrates from the west
of you are afraid these dividing really
the area under the control of the SDF so
progress is being made on the ground it
is not an easy fight and of course there
is a humanitarian crisis unfolding with
the United Nations reporting that
100,000 people have so far been
displaced there is a lot of Western
pressure coming down on Turkey right now
how is turkey dealing with that Zana
yes pressure threats criticism the
United States saying that they're going
to impose economic sanctions if their
red lines are are broken by the Turkish
government in this this offensive but
Turkey is putting on a very brave face
as saying that this operation will
continue this is about our national
security interests and president Erdogan
yesterday made it quite clear that this
operation is not going to stop until the
YPG moves 30 kilometers from the border
with Turkey so reaching that m4 highway
but what he didn't say is how many
kilometers are on the border that they
should leave from is it the 120
kilometer the initial plan or is it the
480 kilometers stretch of territory
which is the so-called safe zone that
turkey wanted to create so the question
this 120 kilometer 30 kilometer pocket
of territory it seems to be and turkey
seems to have a green light from the US
because the US military would true from
that area but the question is will
turkey keep pushing to take the whole
safe zone the 480 by 30 kilometer so
it's still not clear but so far turkey
making it clear the message from here is
no this is not going to stop at least
for the time being over there from our
chuckle a thanks for that let speak now
to egg a setch kidneys in Istanbul he's
a turkey analyst at the political risk
consulting firm IHS market good to have
you with us so first of all how do you
see the issue of Turkey US relations are
they on the brink of another
deterioration that much is for sure
relations have already deteriorated the
issue here is a fundamental
contradiction in US policy for for
whatever reason in 2014 the u.s. did
start supporting a group that was deeply
connected with the sworn enemy of a NATO
ally so the Turks really felt betrayed
from day one and it is of course the
case that now the Kurds also feel
betrayed by the US but it is the case
also that there is this division in US
policy and
that has really had a negative effect on
what has been a decades-long and NATO
alliance the u.s. is now moving towards
sanctions but as far as we know they
haven't actually activated the sanctions
yet why is there room for diplomacy
well mr. Trump appears to have given
president erred on some sort of green
light
he claims that they agreed on limits to
this operation we don't know if that was
actually the case and if so what sort of
limits were talking about it does seem
the case that Trump intends to allow
Turkey to proceed at least with the
first phase of the operation and in the
aftermath restrain the expansion of that
initial territorial pocket but of course
we are seeing the US Congress breaking
ranks with the White House and it may
well go ahead with sanctions of its own
particularly given of course the
bipartisan animosity that mr. Erdogan
appears to really attract now the YPG
the the Kurdish fighters there in Syria
they have links to the PKK which just to
give some background for our viewers
that's a group that's seen in Turkey as
a as a terrorist group it has a history
of doing things like putting bombs in
shopping malls and so on and so forth in
your analysis why has the US and some of
the Western allies found it easy to
overlook that sort of group's history to
be fair I don't think they necessarily
found it easy there was a point in 2014
when the Islamic states had emerged out
of nowhere and there was a sense of
urgency to deal with that problem and
the Kurds really provided a convenient
ground fighting force and and they were
very effective for that purpose I think
many policymakers behind that move for
supporting the YPG were aware of the
fundamental
contradiction resulting from this but of
course at that point the and still it
what is the case is that defeating the
Islamic states and of course keeping it
suppressed is the number one priority
all right we'll leave you there for now
thanks so much again H kin